[Music]
[Applause]
dan wetzel one of our favorite columnist
he writes for yahoo sports joining us on
the program how do you think the
commissioner did in front of congress
yesterday dan
um
for his purposes in the nfl he did quite
well he didn't show up
couldn't be bothered to make it all the
way to washington did it on a zoom
um
they had half of the
representatives
trying to make a mockery of the hearing
talking about you know inflation and all
these other things which are
obviously real world issues but have
nothing to do with the topic at hand so
i don't know whether that was the nfl's
lobbyists who got that done or exactly
how this
this thing went down but it wasn't much
of a grilling
and uh he
did what he did he kind of slipped
through it you know i i have very little
faith in
congress uh let alone these kind of
public forums actually doing anything
against uh something like the nfl which
knows what's what's going on so i
thought for the nfl's purposes it was
fine for every you know trying to find
the truth
uh trying to find transparency
trying to find consistency of argument
not so good but
uh i don't think the nfl cares about
that if i gave you one question for the
commissioner on this topic that question
would be
on this topic um
i would press him on the idea that he
cannot release the report because um
he says you know we we
included we we granted anonymity to
all of the witnesses and many of the
witnesses want it but not all of them uh
there is clearly a way to do this uh the
nhl just did one with the chicago
blackhawks that went through
um you know a sexual assault case that
you know similarly very difficult for
people there is a way to do this by
granting anonymity i would have pounded
that subject the idea that oh i just
can't do it i promised well you
shouldn't have promised if that's what
you know when you promise i'll never
release the report
then you create the idea you can't
release the report but clearly there is
a way to do this with protecting the
anonymity of whoever you speak to that
wants to be
anonymous and maintain that but um
that's a that's not that that idea does
not hold water what are the chances
daniel snyder shows up if he is
subpoenaed
i would expect a very low chance that
daniel snyder ever walks into that room
uh they will fight the subpoena
and you got an election coming in
five months or something i don't know uh
and i'm not a political
expert but there's a decent chance that
uh
the the
that that committee will change
leadership and then that'll be the end
of this report so i my guess is daniel
snyder i mean he's subpoenaed and has to
go he'll go
but i i think he will uh he will be able
to
hold that off and and if there is a
change in leadership this this will this
will peter out uh in the i don't know
220
whatever six or eight year history of
our country rich people versus the
government rich people are undefeated
so i i'm expecting daniel snyder to
avoid that i know you've written a lot
about deshaun watson what kind of week
do you think duchaan watson had this
week
so it's kind of a mixed bag
certainly they settled 20 of the 24
lawsuits that are out there right now
and that is
a step that he needed to get done
the sooner he gets these off the table
and ends sort of the
the drip drip drip of of bad publicity
and headlines and and
uh you know allegations he can start to
confront what he's dealing with and and
you know his goal is to get on the field
um but there's still four remaining uh
including a case by uh ashley solis
who's probably the strongest
um look all the cases are bad all the
cases the allegations are troubling and
all but strictly on a legal
sense if you talk to lawyers and who
analyze all of them
her case is the strongest some of the
stronger ones have stayed
so some of the cases that are
legally a little harder to argue
or he's in more peril a legal peril in
the civil suit
um
gets settled so he's still dealing with
the tough stuff and look at in another
case he said there's four
pending
civil lawsuits involving sexual
harassment sexual assault to a player it
would be massive i mean if we just sat
there and took quarterback x and said
hey you just got hit with four lawsuits
you know everyone's hair would be on
fire the fact that he settled 20
others sort of say oh it's almost over
it's not really over so unless he
settles these last four and they're
going to be harder to do this will carry
through to 2023. if you're if you're
if your goal is to get on the field that
remains a concern because while the nfl
says this has no impact on what they're
going to decide to do
human nature says it does um they don't
want the pr of more details coming out
later or
an actual public trial
where this looks very bad for deshaun
watson and they only suspended him six
games or eight games and then everyone's
saying why didn't you go longer so just
human nature says get this over with and
then maybe you have a shot at lowering
your your your suspension why settle now
why settle this week if you know you're
not going to settle all of these civil
lawsuits
well
this may have been you know they're
they're working with the same attorney
tony busby so
you settle you know however it is it's
like it's almost like a two-part trade i
mean it's
we have to get let's get this out of the
way now let's work on these other four
um so i think the settlement talks on
that and the strength of those cases
again go up when there's only four left
because you know they're going to be
able to
you know if they want to settle i don't
know that i don't know that they want to
but uh civil suit is about money
generally and uh you know almost by
definition is about money sometimes it's
about well i'm gonna hold this person
accountable
but it's a it's it's a negotiation on
what are we gonna pay because there's no
criminality into this uh but with watson
you have a lot of power in trying to
upend his life so we'll see what they go
to but um they can focus on these four
maybe they get it done um maybe they
don't
um but for watson the sooner he gets
them done i think it's just better when
the nfl is sitting there making a
decision he's dan whetsel he's uh the
national columnist for yahoo sports we
had nick faldo on
and
we talked about the live tour
and and he said it feels like there's
something bigger
waiting for those on the live tour now
he didn't he didn't know what it was but
he said it feels like there's something
else attached to this and i'm not quite
sure like what is the end game for the
live tour
i don't know uh you know i
i understand these guys are taking an
enormous amount of money and um
certainly we can be critical of where
that money came from but at the end of
the day all of us are pretty much
looking for a guaranteed you know until
someone's offered that to you and you
say no on principle
um it's hard to be in that position but
right now
it's not good golf i mean
these guys are not the most competitive
golfers it's a 54 hole exhibition it's
not even a regulation golf tournament as
we have known it
uh you will drop out unless the unless
they start making exemptions and this is
where the majors have huge power you'll
drop out of the galt world golf rankings
i mean why should you get world golf
ranking points if you're only playing 54
holes this is practically mini golf
that's gonna be the next thing right
competitive mini golf should get on the
world so these guys are just taking
money in my opinion they're ripping the
saudis off the saudis don't really care
so they're getting has been golfers or
non-competitive golfers what is the
motivation of a bunch of guys who we
already know really aren't that
motivated right now to actually work at
golf because golf is not a sport where
the greatness comes
from how hard you try thursday through
sunday it's how hard you try when you
hit the exact same
bunker shot
10 000 times to the point you're sitting
there on the 18th hole with the us open
and say i gotta hit the shot it is the
grind and that when you put in all those
hours
then you can do the greatness
and what they have right now is a lot of
guys who really aren't trying that hard
already and they faded off in in
competitiveness so what is the
motivation of these guys now when you've
got guaranteed money they only play 54
holes and you don't have a tough field
to play against to put in that work
where you see the greatness so i don't
know i don't know what the goal is i i
guess you know they say well this will
sports wash
you know take the focus off of the saudi
arabian government's uh
um
behavior and and conduct there's
actually more publicity on that yeah
yeah that hasn't worked you know so i
don't know i don't know what the end
goal is i mean i think a lot of guys
gonna make a lot of money and i just
don't know how this becomes really
popular
who wants to watch a 54 hole
about 20 years ago indy car in open
wheel racing split
there was indy car
and there was cart and they split
because there's a fight over money
and the popularity of open wheel racing
plummeted in the united states i was
never quite as big as golf maybe but
everyone started just going to nascar
because it was one circuit and i don't
see how this helps either side of golf
and i don't see how it helps anyone but
the bottom line but if you're brooks
kepca hasn't really you know how how
dialed in has he even been the last few
years um so now you take you're not
building to a ryder cup or you're not
building to a to a u.s open or something
like that i i don't know where he's
gonna have to show a heck of a lot of
ambition that we haven't seen lately
great to catch up with you dan thanks
for joining us thanks dan talk to you
soon dan whetsel yahoo sports national
columnist